Hi, I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to talk about the Kaishiwaza
practice that we do at my school. Um, so
kaishi just means turnover. So
kaiishiwaza means turnover practice.
That's where you're turning over the
techniques. One person's doing it and
then the other person's doing it and
then the other person's doing it. Uh,
whatever it is, the technique, right?
Doing the technique to that person. So
we do it with a knife. Um, it's a real
cool practice. If you want to see the
techniques appear a lot, this practice
will pretty much guaranteed help you see
the techniques a lot. It's a pretty
low-level practice. It's pretty chill.
Like, so it's it's fun to move around. I
compare it to easy rolling in Brazilian
jiu-jitsu. So, if you've ever done
Brazilian jiu-jitsu and someone just
says, "Hey, let's roll." Meaning like,
"Let's just mess around a little. We're
not going to go too crazy on each
other." Then that's what this kind of
practice is for iikido. Um, in lots of
ways it it really lends itself more
towards armed grappling than iikido
specifically, but it's a good tool to
see how the techniques come off. So, I'm
going to call Josh over here. We're
going to go to work.
Josh. All right. So, let's talk about
kaishiwaza as we practice it here in the
dojo. So, the kaishiwaza practice we
have is different than maybe you would
see in other schools. In other schools,
kaiishiwaza when they say kaiuaza,
they're usually talking about a set of
techniques that turn over, right? So
like for example, you know, if Josh
started to do eekyo to me, right? Then I
could step out, do eekyo to him, and
that would be kaiishi. And that's the
same usage of the word we're using. It's
just the practice doesn't look like
that. The practice starts really simply.
One person has the knife and the other
person gets to start with a katori grip,
right? So we start in this configuration
and then from here the objective of the
person with the knife is to get free and
use the knife and and you know use the
knives loose because this is not a
cutting practice right so if the
practice just looked like this that
would be a crummy practice because we
would just be practicing my stabbing
skills and Josh would be practicing his
not getting stab skills but the
objective of this is to actually
practice the technique. So, if I get
free, sure, I'll go to stab Josh, but
it's going to be real slow and chill so
he can actually get it back under
control and then he can start to work
it. Now, also on his side, his objective
is to try to get the knife away from me
so he then has the knife and that's the
kaishi, right? So, like it's switching
over. He's taking the knife so then he
could use the knife on me and I'm taking
the knife so I can use it on him. Now,
when you start this, you guys are going
to do it really terribly, almost
guaranteed because, and I I don't mean
like that your performance of the
techniques is going to be bad. What I
mean is you're going to do it really
hard and crazy and there's a place for
that but that place is really rondor and
that's not the place for this kind of
drill. So it should start out real slow
and Josh and I hopefully will start out
really really slow for you and we'll
kind of build a little bit but so you
know I begin trying to do something like
that. Oh, and I switch and I come around
here like this and I'm trying to get
free and then Josh is getting it and
he's working now. He's got the knife.
Okay. And Josh is coming in at me and
I'm working. Oh, and I got it and I come
back over and he's setting up a
technique. Boom. Boom. Boom. Okay. Okay.
And right now we're going ultra ultra
light and we're not we're not resisting
each other at all. We're just kind of
working the knife. Okay. And that's kind
of where you should start. You could
start this from lots of ways, but just
kind of basically so like you know I
almost give him something, you know? So
like, oh, he's got that niko and I'm not
going to try and take it away from him.
He gives me a yokoi. And that sets up my
kodash and go into here like this. And
then there's a niko yet again. Boom. And
that's the kod. But I'm not going to
take it because I want something
different right now. Sono doesn't matter
what we do. I just didn't want to do
Niko Kota Niko guys over and over. And
if it works out that way, it works out
that way. But what you're building
towards is a more active practice. Now,
if I have the knife away for too long,
I'm just going to present my hand again
and he's going to get it right. Most of
the time though, I'll give it to him in
some kind of cutting action, right? And
he'll work from there to get it out,
right? But when we're going at it, we're
not really giving the knife to each
other at all. We're just kind of trying
to take the knife and get the knife. And
you'll see other techniques appear. So,
it should look like this. Yep.
Nice.
couple.
Okay. So, you get the basic idea from
that. So, you're going to see the
techniques appear over and over again
because you're giving each other the
opportunity to do the techniques. So,
that's not it at its highest level.
you're going to have to go another level
up. You won't see as many techniques,
but for developing the setups for the
techniques, that's the best way to go.
All right. So, I'm Christopher Hine.
Josh Te my song is behind that camera
right there.